ah but you're doing so good what's wrong
with you I don't know I don't know
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Anna Kendrick
chadamy Emmy and Tony Award nominated
actress whose resume includes everything
from acclaimed Broadway performances
beloved indie films and
record-shattering movie franchises her
latest project though is the
psychological Thriller Alice darling
which is currently an exclusively an AMC
Theaters Nationwide Anna Kendrick
welcome to the show thank you so much
for having me
excellent mood right now and things are
gonna go so bad I love I love the
positivity already but you know I
remember we had like a dinner thing last
year a normal dinner normal dinner and
you told me you go I will never ever do
your show I did say that but here we are
just a few months later you're in the
seat I'm curious what changed and how
are you with spicy food someone has a
gun to my head just off camera that's
the only reason I'm here I'm not sure
exactly but I mean I think the show is
wonderful I love watching the show and I
have often thought ugh if they didn't
have to eat all those wings I would love
to go in that show but um not a person
who's good with spice never have been so
um I'm happy that anybody's watching
this just because they want to see me
get tortured I'm in a great mood about
it
[Music]
foreign
like the darkest one so I'm is that like
a psychout thing yeah I would have
assumed that this one would be the
spiciest not an indication not an
indication nobody's safe yeah right okay
can't judge a wing by its cover as they
say
[Music]
what's nice
see
enjoy this because I'm gonna have such a
bad attitude later on oh my God
[Music]
so your latest project Alice darling
tells the story of a woman nearing her
psychological Breaking Point as her
untenable and abusive relationship
bubbles to the surface during a weekend
getaway with her friends and I don't
mean this to sound backhanded but I'm so
used to seeing you in a movie and
immediately falling in love with your
character what did you see as the
challenge or maybe even the opportunity
and playing a character like Alice it
was a little less sort of uh immediately
endearing yeah immediately endearing
yeah that's a that's a good way of
putting it I'm gonna steal that I hope I
don't mind
um yeah I think
um I am much more comfortable or I I
guess I just usually get hired to play
characters where
um I'm supposed to try to be enduring
charismatic Charming funny you know
something there's something that you
like about the character and the idea of
playing a character who is kind of a
bummer just not that fun to be around
and see if it works as a performance and
if people will stick around to end up
rooting for Alice because I think it's
important that the movie starts with you
not really clear on who's the good guy
and who's the bad guy because uh there
were times in your life where you're not
sure like am I the good guy am I the bad
guy and that's sort of like the it's
almost like a mystery film where you're
unfolding like what's actually happening
to this person
oh that's nice
so not to get too meta while you eat
scorching hot chicken wings on a talk
show but I really think of you as like a
true patient zero in this new press era
of celebrities who are asked to do a
whole lot more than just answer
questions what is on a degree of
difficulty like the most challenging
hoop you've been asked to jump through
okay
[Music]
like
um while I was promoting the first Pitch
Perfect movie and I never did it and I
because I knew that I wanted to save it
in case Letterman wanted it because
everyone is afraid of Letterman
including how to save your best stories
for him and you know because he's like
intimidating right but the hardest thing
I ever did was on a British radio show
where I called I was with promoting
trolls I was with Justin Timberlake and
we had to call toy stores and every wait
okay see even describing it
um it was every sentence that I said had
to start with the next letter of the
alphabet
because it's so hard but it seems so
simple that you'll feel really stupid if
you don't do it right so I was really
stressed out about it um I I think I was
hoping that uh Justin was gonna say no
to it and then he did it and I was like
you son of a [__] now I'm gonna do it
so yeah that was that like haunts my
dreams that one
[Music]
okay here's what I will say
so far although I suspect we're gonna
get out of this soon
I can actually still appreciate some
flavor yeah
um without just being like I do not like
this feeling but I think we're you know
heading in the wrong direction but like
it tastes really good but you know you
came in here kind of terrified I can see
it kind of like look at you going in
taking extra bites dropping the
shoulders
um yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to
breathe slowly
what's the most memorable show you
either performed in or saw in South
Portland's lyric Music Theater
sir
the Deep cuts are I mean I shouldn't be
surprised but yeah so that is a theater
where I started doing
um Community Theater I think the this is
embarrassing because I wish it was
something cooler but the very first show
I ever did the very first like music
acting anything I ever did I was like
six or something Annie was the first
thing I was ever in and I was one of the
little orphans but I had a lot of energy
and I do remember
um the uh the director telling all the
girls to stop playing with the dog that
played Sandy and he was like just go
like play with Anna she has too much
energy anyway just like I don't know
like take her for a walk for God's sakes
so she'll calm down
how about uh the Victoria Mansion Tour
overrated or underrated oh um
this is crazy uh the Victoria Mansion
Tour I think is pretty fun I mean I
don't know if you're from somewhere that
has cool [__] maybe you're gonna be like
it's just a house it's just like a nice
old house my dad passed recently and he
had a collection of Christmas ornaments
that are from like a local jeweler they
do every year like a Portland landmark
and I know that me and my brother are
gonna end up fighting over the Victoria
Mansion one because that's kind of like
uh the OG one the Victoria Mansion is
the thing in our city that makes us feel
classy
[Music]
okay number four
oh God
[Music]
huh oh it is oh
should I get something bad
is it true that you asked for an
additional take something that you
rarely do on the set of get a job
because you weren't satisfied with your
bong rep oh wow that's really
interesting I never put this together
I did the same thing on Mike and Dave
need wedding dates about a bong rip oh
yeah yeah you got it I forgot yeah the
scene where me and Aubry Plaza and Mike
and David wedding dates are sitting on
the couch and and there was like just
this joke where I'm supposed to like
take a big rip off the bong and then say
a line
and I remember the director and I just
couldn't like because it's not real weed
it behaves weirdly and
um and I couldn't get like the perfect
pull and then blow and the line right
like it wasn't really singing and he was
like it's okay we've got a lot of
coverage on this and I was like I know
you're going to want to use this in the
two shot I know you are and he was like
I mean you're right I do want to use it
in the two shot so that was the other
time that I was like come on Coach give
me one more give me one more foreign
[Music]
I'm doing that thing did all the guests
do where they're like it's not that bad
oh God right oh
but going back in
I'm trying cursing yourself in the
experience love it love to see it
oh yep
don't freak out don't freak out don't
freak out yeah Sean don't freak out John
why are you freaking
you're doing great you're doing great
fact or fiction many of the actors who
were fired on up in the air weren't
actually actors but real life people who
were recently laid off and then
instructed to react as if they wish they
would have yeah um that's exactly right
there were a bunch of people and at
first I remember that idea sounding like
a little wonky and it turned out so well
um although I did actually feel bad for
Zach Galifianakis because it's like when
people start singing in a musical the
first time you're even if you like
musicals it's like oh right now this is
happening yeah yeah
um and uh yeah I did like feel slightly
bad for Zach Galifianakis for having to
like kind of start the acting phase of
the movie after all this really raw
intense emotion
[Music]
I gotta keep up with you
the going for the extra bite
feels like now I gotta do this but then
even just licking my thumb then I go why
you didn't have to do that you know
different types of guests come in here
and react different ways like an athlete
you can almost see their like just one
more rep kind of thing in them but with
actors sometimes like they actually eat
more and I'm wonder and I think it's
like to immerse themselves in like the
experience more or something I wonder if
it's because a lot of actors
genuinely have a pet peeve about like
scenes where no one really eats anything
I there's a scene in The Bodyguard where
um Whitney Houston and Kevin Costner are
having a drink at like Barney's Beanery
and he is holding this beer He he'll be
about to take a sip of the beer and then
her line comes and I'm like just drink
the beer Kevin drink the beer Kevin so
I wonder if there's like a I have to eat
it otherwise it'll come across like
really corny
you're doing great you're doing better
than I expected you to are you doing
better than you honestly are you doing
better than you expected I well I I mean
I guess just based on the pure numbers
although
um uh Justin Timberlake did warn me oh
yeah that
um that he did the show and he was like
by the end of it like you feel drunk and
I'm just beginning to get a little bit
of a like sort of hey Sean yeah what's
going on with everybody sort of a
weightlessness yeah
neck it's nice and so far it's really
Pleasant and I'm just gonna enjoy that
because
um I think it's gonna get unpleasant
really soon well we're not gonna blow
the high just yet you know I'm not gonna
blow the high just yet I think we'll
just enhance a little bit and what a
sauce by the way to enhance on with this
one right here dreams of calypso you
know that's only gonna take us higher
if you say so you son of a [__] okay
okay
[Music]
I really don't like that they taste good
at first yeah like it's almost like
manipulative you know right they put a
little like pineapple in there a little
mango so it's like a little bit that's
really that's really really nice and
then I can feel that it's about to start
hurting me yeah you're a bad person this
mermaid is a bad mermaid
so I've heard you declare your love of
films from the 30s and 40s which is a
time period that even the most devoted
Criterion Collection fan may not know a
lot about off the top of your head and
without thinking about it too much can
you recommend a film or two as an
on-ramp to that era of Hollywood
filmmaking sure um well the women is my
favorite um film of all time it's from
1939.
um I love Arsenic and Old Lace like
there's something
um there's something so charming and
endearing about Cary Grant discovering
that his two spinster aunts are are
murdering tenants but it's like a
slapstick comedy but then it gets really
dark like Peter Laurie shows up and it
gets really [__] up and then at one
point he's like tied up and you're like
oh he's so cute you know like sweet
little sweet little
um Cary Grant just being
um okay Anna
I was racing through that yeah it's just
it's just it just it just came to a
screeching halt and that's okay I'm not
sure if it was Peter Laurie please
um uh please cut that if it's not Peter
Lurie in the in the film
ah okay what are the perfect atmospheric
conditions for a Lord of the Rings watch
party
[Music]
yeah that's what happens that's what
happens that's what I'm chasing
laughs
I can feel it
okay this is really interesting
okay because
you can tell that I'm feeling stoned
because I'm talking like in my
headphones
um because
I feel like I okay I took a break from
smoking weed for like a good couple
years because it was starting to just
make me paranoid and now that it's like
legal and regulated I've been dipping my
toe back in but there's still that like
kind of paranoia that attempt the other
direction
um but obviously I did not know that
this was available to me I don't care
for the pain but this is fun the
physiological yeah yeah this feels like
similar to like getting high with my
roommate when I was like 20 and like
walking to Ralph's and having like
Stoner obstacles yeah like an innocent
giggly High uh-huh
this is great
[Music]
okay
it's a bomb Beyond Insanity okay
it's gonna get me on me no you look
great you're good
and this is like where we might kind of
blow the high
[Music]
no not at all
yep yeah
we got it happy place wait why the ears
why the ears Sean ears I don't know
about
like are they like popping like an
airplane kind of yep
why that I don't that that's new that's
new that's
if people having their ears popped
everybody comes back everybody comes
back everybody comes back down to earth
okay we make it we make it how about now
this feels like that scene in Aladdin
when he's like get on the Magic Carpet
he's like can you trust me and I'm like
no Sean I don't [__] trust you
anymore no I under I get that I did that
okay
okay all right this is so much fun yeah
you're having a good time yeah you
remember that bad attitude I was talking
about oh it's coming I'm ready for it
and I deserve it but you're doing so
good what's wrong with you dudes I don't
know I don't know
do people do this without getting upset
at you
you know it's a it's a range it's always
kind of like an emotional roller coaster
you know like sometimes you get like
there's like a little bit of like trauma
bonding that happens sometimes it goes
the opposite direction sometimes I make
lifelong friends doing this show you
know what I mean like it really is a
range of emotions okay but I understand
totally I'm literally trying to think of
an experience in my life to compare this
to and one is not kidney stones I guess
the kidney stones where it feels like
things are kind of coming in and out of
the room yeah like things are
disappearing and it's just you and me
yeah and so far you haven't left yet
right I'm still here but oh still
connected nobody else is in the room
nobody else it's just you and me and
like a black abyss of pain it's like the
end of the wood set you know it's like
The Truman Show where who knows where it
ends
right right
okay
in a 2015 interview with stylist UK you
talked about how eating macaroni and
cheese is kind of a post-award show
ritual for you yeah all in what would
you say is the most extravagant or
expensive Ensemble that you've ever worn
while just like housing easy pack oh I
mean
I I think um probably the the Met Gala
you feel like maybe I'm actually really
fancy you know I was in a museum all
night and then you go home you're just
eating mac and cheese and yeah to have
that in the experience of the the peak
of masquerading as a kind of glossy
facade of what you thought the Pinnacle
of Hollywood was it's really beautiful
and it's really eye-opening but not
eye-opening the way that this is this
makes me want to die
[Music]
sometimes when I'm shooting I am so cold
and it's not cold like discomfort it's
cold like I'm suffering yeah and then
they call Action and I have to just be
fine right okay so give me a little
countdown and call Action okay but I'm
really gonna try to take it seriously
all right okay quiet on the set quite
unset
quiet on set I hate all of you foreign
and
action okay
incredible it's pretty good incredible
what role did the store yellow rat
bastard play in shaping your personal
style as a young actor
oh Jesus it was a product of its time
and okay it was a product of his time
and um so you know style changes taste
changes and
you know so you can't just know like oh
how would I feel about that as an adult
but I can say that you know
when I was like 12 in the late 90s I
just thought it was the coolest [__]
store in history
um but I remember like wearing them uh
as a freshman in high school and just
thinking
I was so cool such a badass that I had
like
a t-shirt that said orgy on it or
something I don't know the Baywatch tea
the Baywatch tea yeah yeah and the fact
that like it would be like oh I got it
in New York you know I really felt um
some type of way about that
all right Kendrick what's happening
what's happening Sean
you don't have to yes I do oh okay then
I won't stop you oh okay
[Music]
does that look that looks great textbook
okay all right
cheers see you in hell
[Music]
oh God
hmm oh God I bit it too fast and I think
some of it went in my face oh God
we'll find out in a second
but you know
the good news is Anna Kendrick we have
slayed the hot sauce dragon as Viola
Davis would say and just one more hoop
before we get you out of here don't
worry
not gonna bust out the clutch or play
the Ante Up instrumental but what I want
to do is take you back through this
journey you know your love of Cinema
starts with this this passion for movies
from the 30s and 40s nominated for a
Tony Award when you're 12 years old and
then becoming one of the most prolific
actors over the last two decades but to
close it out my question is how has
working in the business of Hollywood for
so long how is it enhanced or detracted
from the enjoyment that you get out of
movies oh God I feel like
first of all I don't know how you talk
coherently during this so my hat's off
um thank you but
I think um wait one more lady like yep
okay
I think that
when you start making movies there's a
there's a period where they're kind of
ruined for you because you're just
thinking about like all the behind the
the scenes and the how the sausage gets
made of it all and now
I feel like it's uh it's just sort of
second nature that's like a running
script in the back of my head and so
when a movie is really bad it's so much
worse because it's like I can see like
why that choice and it would have been
so easy to just do this or whatever and
when it's good the running script is not
just like I'm immersed in the movie and
it's great there's a thing in the
background of like oh my God like every
department just nailed it and I kind of
get this like bonus appreciation for all
these people that came together and made
this thing
and I'm gonna pretend that I'm just
really emotional about it
and that's why
I'm breathing really heavy and I'm
sweating and
[Music]
maybe gonna pass out I just love movies
so much it's all a character choice and
look at you Anna Kendrick taking on the
wings of death living to tell the tale
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
[Music]
I don't know I'm falling apart
I'm finding myself I'm becoming a new
woman
you know God's working on all of us
every day is a New Journey it's one step
at a time I have a movie out but
whatever man see it don't see it
do what makes you happy and don't do
this if you do this on the regular
I don't know um my hat's off I love you
all
[Applause]
I don't know what's happening right now
ah okay
okay
I don't know I think it might have been
I think I might have been around as bad
as I thought it was gonna be
uh
okay be honest yeah did I have like
Blair Witch snap bubbles throughout
hot ones fans breaking news the three
and one boneless bites challenge is back
for a limited time you can put your
taste buds to the test against some of
our most iconic flavors the classic Los
Calientes and the peak of heat Apollo
but don't fret hot ones fans even when
the three in one challenge leaves the
freezer aisle you can still pick up your
favorite flavor of hot ones boneless
bites visit hotoneschallenge.com for
more information on products and to find
a store near you because it's time to
bring the Heat home